- All right, good morning.
Thank you all for joining the session.
I'm Lakshman, a partner in PWC.
I manage our tech and analytics
for financial services.
I'm really excited to
have Matt and Solomon,
the risk technology leadership
of Capital One, join us.
Matt is the managing vice
president of product.
He focuses on their product strategy.
And then we have Solomon,
who's the vice president
of software engineering.
He focuses on like
architecture implementation
and building the risk
positioning platform.
Now, I wrote the business
case for this session,
and part of the reason was because I work
with a lot of other financial
services institutions.
Almost everyone chose to
buy a vendor solution.
There are a number of solutions
available in this space.
Capital One had the
forethought back in like 2019
to build something natively in AWS.
Now, it's become more obvious
because of the capabilities
of AWS has evolved so much.
And then some of the vendor solutions
are pretty restrictive,
but we are seeing the
benefits of that decision.
So I thought we'll get them on the stage,
have them speak about the process
in which they went through.
I have some questions prepared.
I'm gonna go through the questions,
and towards the end we'll open up for QA.
So feel free to ask any
questions in the end.
I'll start with the first question,
and then, Matt and Solomon, feel free
to introduce yourself as we get started.
The first question is,
Capital One is often described
as a software company
that happens to be a bank.
How does that philosophy
show up in your approach
to governance, risk, and compliance?
Start with you, Matt.
- Sounds good.
So as Lakshman said, I am
head of product management
for risk management at Capital One,
so responsible for all the software
that we build that
Capital One associates use
to manage risks ranging from things
like investigating money laundering
to investigate it or to
managing issues and events.
And when I think about your
question here, you know,
as you said, Capital One
is a technology company.
We happen to be a technology company
in the financial services space.
And we say, you know, as a bank,
risk management is our business.
And we put those things together.
You know, one of the things Solomon
and I really focus on is like,
how can we transform risk
management with technology?
And I think that's how
you get that alignment
with the business and aligning risk,
technology, compliance going forward.
And yeah.
- Solomon, anything you wanna add to that?
- Yes, thanks for having us.
Like Lakshman said, I'm in Capital One.
I've been with Capital one 14 years.
I'm in the engineering
space building software,
in the risk space for
the last five, six years.
It's been pretty exciting.
To answer, you know,
to the question itself,
if you think about how at Capital One
we look to solve problems
for our business,
it's fundamentally changed
since we've become a cloud-native company.
So while we've started to change our ways
to approaching how we build software
and solving business,
the GRC problem comes
along a few years ago,
and then it was no different
when we looked at it and said,
is this a competitive
advantage and can we do it?
And I think because of
the journey we've been on
on our AWS journey and, you know,
the evolution of risk management,
the confluence allowed
us to, I think, you know,
start this GRC journey ourselves.
- Thank you.
Matt, next question for you.
I wanna talk about the initial vision.
What is the North Star
when you started building this platform?
- Yeah, our overarching goal
is to build real-time
intelligent risk management.
And I think a lot of risk management work
in practice ends up
being documenting things
that have happened, but
we want to have a platform
that really helps people to
proactively manage risks,
anticipate things before they occur,
minimize the impacts of
things that do occur.
And I think if we really focus
on this theme of real-time intelligent,
one, we'll deliver way
better user experiences
to all those people around Capital One
that are using our software,
and, two, deliver way
better risk management
for the business.
- Yeah, I remember like
working with you back in 2019
when none of the other banks,
or at least the risk management tech,
were not focused on user experience.
That was like a first thing
that you guys focused on
even before we came up with requirements.
That was interesting.
Anything you want to add Solomon about?
- It's surprising the number of users
we have on our product.
We have roughly 10,000
internal Capital One users
who use our platform.
So you think about building a software
that is world class for
our internal customers,
and not only is the software
supposed to be world class,
but it's also forward-leaning
where we try to do things
that are different than, you know,
if it's gonna be the business,
risk management is your business,
the value we attach to the solution
and the platform is a lot different.
And that was, I think,
a part of the vision
is not to mimic what was already
in the marketplace in this space,
and I think we have great
products, of course,
but what we wanted to set to achieve
not so that, you know, Matt talked about
that is truly something
that doesn't exist.
And we said, hey, we want
to go there ourselves.
So, the vision is to provide a service
for our 10,000 risk
officers or risk managers,
if you would, at Capital One,
a way to do their jobs better.
- Okay.
All right, both of you
mentioned risk being core
to the business, right?
And it's not just a control function.
So how does that mindset influence
the way you design technology?
Solomon, you wanna take that?
- Yeah, so when we set on this path,
what we realized was this is, you know,
at an abstract level, an
object model and design, right?
You think about objects as risks,
controls, issues, and events.
So when we start to boil down
an abstract at that level,
we are like, hey, what
does the system look like
you know, that is able to scale
and be flexible with object handling?
That's where we ended up,
and that was the first
version of the product,
the first version of what
we started to build out.
And as we start to, you know,
get into the 2023, 2024,
a couple of years in,
we realized the object
relationships are critical,
and all of a sudden it
allows us to interact
or technically transact
with these objects.
That's where, if you look at the design,
you know, that's the design.
What it has allowed us
to do is it allowed us
to move from a product
mindset to a platform mindset.
So now that you have objects,
you've created the relationships,
and you're able to interact,
now we have an assessment as a transaction
with these objects,
and all of a sudden these
things become alive,
and it's less and less like
what we started off with,
which is reactive risk
management to now the proactive.
I think the next step is what
Matt hit on the vision stuff.
- I think that's a great view
that like architecture design,
as I think about like the
user experience design,
as you said we have 10,000
users across the company,
every line of business
and every line of defense.
We want our software to be so good
that our product is in
demand across the company.
And you can tell me, but I'm guessing
there aren't a lot of businesses out there
where people like love their
risk management software,
but we sort of set that as a goal
we wanna work backward from.
You know, Solomon referenced
like we want world-class experiences.
Like Capital One uses net promoter scores
to see how our credit card
customers are feeling.
We use net promoter scores
to see how our GRC users are feeling.
And you know, we've gone on a journey
from like way negative to mildly positive,
but we're gonna keep going
until we have like a product
that people are demanding,
and you know, we want
business leaders coming to us.
So most of our users are not like
in the risk management organization.
They're out in the business
running the company,
and I want them to say, this is a product,
this is a platform that
helps me do my job better,
it helps me understand my risks better.
- Yeah, I've not come
across any other banks,
risk technology having NPS.
And I've seen the tracking
go higher and higher,
which is like amazing.
And the other thing I've
noticed, even for the...
I mean, GRC used to be the old term.
They changed to IRM, right,
integrated risk management.
Even with the new
cloud-native vendor products
that are there, I've seen like
large financial institutions,
when somebody's responsible
for building the RIG change management,
somebody else is for issues management,
and they both create like
their own data model,
creating duplicates, which
was a traditional issue.
And having the object model,
that's so you have one set of
risk, controls, regulations
that's used across, I think,
that like makes the
reporting and all that easy.
So follow-up question, Solomon.
So, how does the risk real-time
decision making look like
in practice for risk teams?
And how did cloud-native
design make that achievable?
- So if you think about real time,
the need for real time is now, right?
So if you think about where
we are as as a species, right,
with the internet and the connectivity,
everything is connected.
So when you think about
what your boundaries were,
it's not even the international
boundaries anymore.
You're affected by markets
across the world, for example.
So if you're in a financial
firm and you have financial
and non-financial risk
that you're managing,
real-time risk management
is scanning the horizon
to understand what your risk ratings are
relative to what you thought
they were supposed to be,
but if you have a stationary
backward-looking way
of scoring a risk, then you're
not gonna be able to react
to what I think are changes
that are now available
in real time for you to react to, right?
You have the social media,
the sentiment analysis,
all kinds of things that are available.
And then on the flip side,
we talked about internal
customers, Matt and I.
We also have the regulators
as a customer of ourselves as well.
So we are here to serve them
because they ultimately make us successful
and safe for the customers
that we care about.
So again, you think about
real-time intelligence
is also understanding how
the regulators want us
to prove how safe we are.
So you start to think about the needs
of the market are changing.
So real time is not
something that we want to do,
it's something we have to do.
So now you then you switch
to the cloud-native version
of your application.
That allows you to have...
You know, we are lucky at at Capital One
to have the entire ecosystem on the cloud.
So now as new services
become available to AWS,
we are able to leverage them.
We're able to buy what we
think are commodity products
or services to tack on
while we focus on features
that are truly setting us apart
in the integrated risk
management tech space.
So real time for me is not, hey,
we are doing it and we are special.
It's something that we
think you have to do,
and we are able to do it
because of the cloud-native
aspect of our application.
- Anything you wanna add, Matt?
- No.
- Yeah, I mean, I think this
makes a big difference, right?
Like back in 2008 financial crisis,
I know like Lehman, (indistinct),
they all had like a large
risk management teams,
but they were not able to
hedge, and even recently
with Silicon Valley Bank,
Signature, et cetera,
I think it's truly not having
a real-time risk management platform
that caused part of the issues they faced.
So let's move into security.
I got a couple of questions on this.
One, Capital One has been
vocal about treating security
as an engineering discipline.
What does that look like day to day?
- I'll try to take a shot at this.
So, you know, if you boil down what we do
for a living in international services,
we are taking care of someone,
our customers' money, right?
It's something that's very
personal and very attached
to a lot of their own
successes and dreams.
So it's something that we have
to take extremely seriously,
and it's actually a bedrock
of, I think, how Capital One thinks.
You know, if you look at our strategies,
it's always been foundationally
about the customers
and since we handle a very
personal part of their lives.
So for me, security is a
couple of versions, right?
One is the data that we use,
which is again very critical
to our decisioning at the
same time needs to be secure.
So we have pretty, you know, a
high sophisticated encryption
for data at rest.
And then when you transmit, so S3,
and we have versions on AWS
that we're able to leverage.
And then in terms of
the application itself,
we have pretty, you know, interesting,
sophisticated identity management,
and then the app level
securities is something
we have inherent from the cloud,
provided in this case AWS.
You know, in addition to
all these three things,
the developer velocity,
the velocity in which
we are producing code
has dramatically increased in Capital One.
We have, you know, a lot of engineers.
So now we have to have the
engineering discipline start
with first being, you know, secure.
So we have invested a
ton of time and money
in developer tools that
your very first step
is to be writing code that is secure.
So we've come at it from all three levels
because, like I said, it's
extremely important to us,
so we want to make sure it's done right.
- Got it.
Back when I was a developer,
you generally build the application first,
and then you go through a security review,
they give recommendations,
and then you just try to meet it.
So, I think you covered
it part of it, right?
Like how did you...
Was there anything specific you did
to embed security into
your development lifecycle
than just bolting it on the end?
- Like I said, step one.
- Yeah.
- So from the time you
check code into GIT,
the security level at the code base level,
and then we have...
I think we've tried to stay
on top of all the scans
as they become available.
They've gotten better and better.
And again, it allows us to scan
and then to remediate the vulnerabilities
because we are on the
cloud versus you know?
Trying to stay ahead
of the vulnerabilities
is a very key lift we get
from being on the cloud
and automatic, you know,
infrastructure development, right?
Infrastructure as code
allows us to stay in front.
- Got it.
So next session is the
more interesting one,
at least for me, because Capital
One is one of the very few,
I mean probably the only
financial institution
that built its own platform,
whereas everybody...
There is strength in numbers, right?
Almost every other bank buys one
of their traditional GRC solution,
and the challenge they face
is you have one solution
or one vendor for RIG change management,
another for like GRC,
and then one for AML,
one for RIG reporting.
And there's like many of them,
the challenge they face is,
how do you integrate it
specifically for reporting, right?
There is like redundant data in there.
I was like amazed that like again,
six years ago, you guys made the decision
to build it and that to in AWS.
Now, the more I see in the market,
I think as the AWS
features are ramping up,
it makes more sense.
And I also see a lot of PE companies
buy these vendor solutions,
and licensing fees goes up.
So, I mean, it's just brilliant
that you guys decided like
six years ago to do it.
So Matt, for you,
so many organizations might default
to buying GRC solution off the shelf.
Why did you decide to build instead?
- Yeah, ultimately, we view GRC
as one of the cores of risk management.
Many of our most important
risk management functions
as a company are in this platform,
whether it's assessing
risks or testing controls
or managing issues and events,
adhering to regulatory
requirements, as you said.
Those are some of the most
important things we do
in all of risk management
are all in one place.
So the functionality is
critically important.
And then we'd already touched
on sort of the user scale.
You know, we have 10,000 users,
every line of business,
every line of defense.
This isn't a, you know,
bespoke tool for one audience.
This has the biggest potential
to reshape risk management as the company.
So we viewed this
as like, you know, we wanna be selective
about where we're making
these big investments
and big bets and and
viewed GRC as one of them.
Just to give a counterpoint,
there's another area of risk management
where we were on a path to
build an in-house platform,
and we actually stopped
that work earlier this year.
And if you just put that
through the same lens,
it was like tens of users,
not thousands of users,
and they were all in one department.
And you know, there's vendor solutions
that do the thing pretty good,
and there's obviously pretty
good GRC solutions as well,
but like this is an area
where we don't think
pretty good is good enough.
Like this is where we can really shape
how we approach risk as a company.
- Solomon, anything you want to add?
- First is like, you
know, Matt had the trust
in our team to say let's
go build it, right?
So fundamentally, you know,
it was an opportunity for
the engineering team as well.
But for us, we did have two GRC platforms
that we had bought from vendors.
What we thought it lacked
was the flexibility for the business.
And as the business starts
to reimagine risk management,
like Matt, you know, he clearly said
it's not a cost play for us
if we wanna do it exceptionally well.
And then when you start
looking at the platforms
that, you know, we were
buying or we had in-house,
they wouldn't allow us
to do certain things
the way we wanted to.
So we felt that we were getting boxed in.
And so we started a little
bit of a peeling off
layer by layer approach first.
And then, like I said,
the object architecture,
like when we got to, can
we define the object,
the metadata, and the
interactions with them,
then it started to kind of fall in place.
We did have a couple of false starts.
We kind of reset a little bit,
but it was done for the right reasons,
but we also had a very patient business
because they could see the vision,
and their vision was
slightly aspirational,
which didn't kind of work
with what was in the market for us.
- Got it.
Yeah, just so, Matt, back to you, right,
what are some of the tradeoffs,
right, like between...
I mean, these vendor companies
have spent a lot on R and D.
They have a lot of like peer experience
building the solutions over the years.
So what are some of the tradeoffs
that you had to deal with
when you made this decision?
- Yeah, I think as Solomon
said, it's not like a cost play.
It's not, you know, we
can do this on the cheap,
but I think ultimately it comes down
to that element of like the
flexibility and control.
We can build the risk management
exactly the way we want it,
and, you know, we can
continually customize it.
We don't need to fit our risk management
into, you know, what is
the best possible solution
with the container that's been
given to us by a third party.
We can create what we want,
develop that strategy and roadmap.
We have no shortage of
leaders around the company
coming to us with ideas.
You know, it's always a good situation
to have a longer backlog
than capacity to deliver it,
but you know, when I see
that I think, gosh, I'm glad
that we control this entirely ourselves
versus, you know, whoa, we'll
go talk to another company
and see if we can make
this type of thing work.
- Got it.
So, I mean, my view, right,
even though most of my clients
are like banks in the East Coast,
I've spent fair amount of time
in Silicon Valley as well.
I mean, their approach,
when I deal with CRO CCOs
is not look at like what others are there.
And I felt like, you know,
from an engineering point of view,
the example I use is when
Uber designed the software,
they didn't go and look
at like what software
taxi companies are using.
So same way you guys didn't look at,
hey, what is the leading GRC platform?
Let's copy their features.
So, my question is, how did
your engineering culture
and tech capabilities make the building
of this solution possible?
- A couple of people in the audience
are part of that journey.
So I'm very proud to have them on my team.
The idea of...
So when you look at
what the platforms were,
so when we said what are the features
that we wanted to pivot on,
one was the flexibility of
the object handling itself.
A second was the quality of data
that we wanted to capture
by object was key.
So the metadata handling by object
and then how we wanted
to try interact with it
was, I think, different
than what the others had.
They wanted to have a very
straightforward workflow.
So when we started to
peel these things off,
we said, hey, the workflow's
gonna be separate,
the objects are gonna be separate,
the metadata is gonna be flexible.
Then we started to put
those things together.
Then we were able to...
Like I said, it was not a all in.
We moved a couple of objects first.
The risks moved over first.
The controls moved over second.
So we had a path.
And then when we start to see some success
and then the backlog that
Matt was talking about
started to load up, which means we started
to see customers actually get attracted
to the way we were thinking
about the solution,
then I think it kind of took a second.
Like I think the second
wind was a lot different.
We put a lot more investment in it.
Now the number of teams increased.
The kind of things we
built changed as well.
- Got it, and when you built the software,
you didn't expect that
Discover acquisition.
So Discover as, you know,
they were using a traditional
like a GRC platform as well.
So, how was that integration?
Now you build the solution.
It's live.
And obviously when you're
migrating the existing data
from Discover, was that like a challenge,
or do you have to make any
changes to your platform?
How did you still like, you know, manage
to stay ahead of this emerging risks
and regulatory expectations?
- Yeah, so we haven't
done the integration yet,
but we are going to,
and I think this is one
of the big advantages we have of,
we're gonna bring a bunch of new users in,
we're gonna bring all that extra data in,
and our platform is just gonna scale.
We are gonna change some things
'cause we're entering new business lines.
We need to customize some fields.
We need to...
There's new sort of regulatory
risks we need to consider,
but again, we own the backlog,
and we can make that prioritization
and make those make those changes.
Ultimately, there's a huge advantage
of our regulators are familiar
with the way Capital One
does risk management,
and the way we do risk management
is built into our GRC platform.
So when Discover comes in,
they will inherit our
risk management posture
simply by inheriting our software.
- Got it, anything you wanna add, Solomon?
- I mean, Matt kind of brushed by it,
but the regulators have been a part
of our journey too.
The entire, it's not something...
We actually talked to the
regulators about the fact
that we are building our own platform,
and they were getting periodic updates
on the platform as we built it.
That was key.
And then this whole Discover migration,
I've been through a few myself,
but the way we looked at this
migration was way different
simply because we owned the embedded logic
that implemented the policy
that we wanted to implement.
So now you're like, hey,
the policy's already a part of the code,
so when you bring users on,
users inherit the policy.
So the training aspects of it,
more importantly, following,
I think, our practices
versus Discover practices,
would've been a bigger
change management event
than it ended up being.
It ended up being, and
then like Matt said,
we are on the path of
merging with Discover
over the next couple of months.
- You mentioned regulators a few times,
and you said regulators as a customer.
I mean, generally they seem
to be like an afterthought
for most people.
Do you give access to the regulators or...
Yeah?
- Yeah.
- That's very interesting.
So I mean, no session is
complete without discussing AI.
So next question is, how
do you see risk compliance
and AI converging in the
next three to five years?
- I think all the other rooms
have a lot more answers to AI than us.
I think, you know, for us, risk
management is the business.
So Matt and I are part of
the risk management team.
For us, managing the
risk that AI introduces
is for me more than as an engineer
I'm looking at AI as a fun way
of solving for my customers as well.
I weigh both.
And I think, you know, AI
in risk management is going
to allow us to be this whole
real time and more proactive.
I think we've already
seen a couple of instances
where when the regulations come in,
to understand the regulation summarization
and theming is already something
that we have in the marketplace today.
PWC has a version of the product already
that is very extremely,
you know, engineered.
It's a beautiful product actually.
But now you're talking
about GenAI going past that,
which should be themes on loads
and loads of data against the history
and to see and predict and
say, hey, what the risks are.
I think that's gonna be very exciting,
and I'm assuming the regulators
will have a very pointed
view on how we manage risk.
Do we listen to the AI
model and manage risk,
or do we do it ourselves?
So that's gonna be an
interesting next couple of years.
But more importantly,
the fact that the product
that we built, the GRC product,
as we start to increase
this whole net scale,
scale of functionality,
we manage controls, risks, and issues now,
think about managing an
object, which is just a model.
The machine learning model,
MLM, small language model.
These are all now things
that have to be governed
to perform within the boundaries
of a financial services.
So that for me, I think we
are positioned really well
because we can now scale our GRC platform
to be a part of that risk management.
- So you're not really waiting for vendors
to add AI capabilities
because it's cloud native.
When AWS releases new features,
you're able to integrate it
and make it future proof.
- Yeah.
- So one, I know we've discussed
this in the past, right,
like currently, I mean, part
of the like regulatory function
is to do the reporting, right?
You do YNC, call report, liquidity report,
daily liquidity report, right, 2052a,
and the regulators use all this data
to look at the stability of the bank.
They also try to see...
They kind of compare what they get
versus the management reports.
With your like, you
know, single data model,
you can make sure there is consistency.
Any view on how the regulatory
expectations might change
over the, you know, next
three to five years?
- I'll go to Matt.
(Matt laughs)
Matt meets with them every day, so.
- You know, I think the
expectations will continue to rise.
I think they'll continue
to be more of a focus
on, you know, how are we leveraging AI
and where should we be leveraging AI
and what are the risks of AI.
I think the broader risk
management environment
continues to get more complex.
I think expectations of
banks will rise over time,
and, you know, we need to be
able to keep pace with that.
- Yeah, definitely.
And I think, Solomon, you
mentioned before, right,
like on how regulators
instead of using this tabulated format,
which is where like a lot of
the effort is spent currently
on doing the reporting,
they could potentially
access your data through API.
- See, I mean, when you
say you can engineer
at scale, right, it goes both ways.
So it's one thing for us
as a company to do this,
which we are on our journey.
I'm assuming the regulators
are on their own journey
in using technology
to make their governance
processes bigger or better.
In this case, you do a sample
test, you can go to full file.
If I do full file, so can
the regulators, right?
So now the data, it's on
an S3 bucket on the cloud.
If I can write an API call, so can they.
So now you start to see the confluence
of their engineering catching up
or even sometimes going faster than we are
in terms of how they consume data.
All of a sudden, we
have to meet them there.
So I feel like that's where it's gonna go,
and it's already starting,
of all places in Australia actually
is that the regulators
actually have a full file test
as a part of their process.
It hasn't come to the west
yet, but it's not far away.
- Definitely, and I've
seen a number of banks,
they have like three lines of defense.
Each of them do like a
sample based testing,
and they still miss things.
And regulators come in,
they're like smarter
on how they pick samples,
and I've seen situations
where they pick like selected sample
and find like 90% error rate,
they need to go redo it,
and depends on what you pick,
how you test it, et cetera.
So the full file testing
seems to be the future.
And the challenge with
that is access to the data,
which most institutions struggle.
I know CFPB tried to do that
with a lot of their data collection,
but I think with the
current administration
that's not active.
I do think it's a good
opportunity right now
that the enforcement actions
have reduced the staffing
for the regulators have reduced.
And since like financial crisis,
in order to banks to show
that they're taking regulators seriously,
they've been building up the
risk management function.
And I feel like now with the less scrutiny
might be a perfect opportunity
to go back and like automate,
like, you know, people are
talking about agent take AI
and other things to doing it.
It looks like you guys have a
good foundation for all that.
- I think that exists already now, right?
So that doesn't have to be in the future.
That's something we are
looking at right now
is the automation of the controls testing.
We have data products at Capital One.
We take data extremely seriously.
It's very precious to us.
It's what the company's founded on
is our way we analyze data
to run our businesses.
So you think about right
now what we're trying
to tackle is the automation
of the controls testing.
Like we can test the controls
much, you know, often
than we do right now.
The cadence can be much more frequent.
So those are things that
are already existing now.
That's not gonna be an AI play.
It's gonna be something that anybody
with good data stewardship
should be able to do.
That's one of the things that we're trying
to think about as well.
- Yeah, one thing I found interesting,
the way you approach, Solomon,
is that you took the software engineering.
It used to be software development cycle.
I develop, give it to
Matt, he'll go test it,
and then there is integrated
testing and then you release.
So you've taken the concept
of the CICD pipeline
and brought it into risk management.
Can you talk about it?
- Well, the idea is, you know,
a CICD pipeline is essentially
a risk management play
on a software engineer to prevent a bug
from going into production by scans.
And, you know, early on testing
with a lot of automation reduces the risk
of a problem happening in production.
So a risk management practice
is nothing different.
And like, you don't want
a risk to realize, right?
That's the sense of
what we're trying to do.
So now when you look at,
I don't wanna go into the numbers,
I'm not allowed to, I'm saying,
but we have x number of
risks and we control them,
and they have various scores.
And so when you have
something that is testable,
why does it need to be
tested once every six months
if you have the data and
the testing is automatable
and, you know, we have the data
and we can get to a much
more frequent version
of the testing is our vision.
So while not the whole suite,
we can't test the whole
control, all the controls,
we are looking at the ones
that are, you know, closer
to the engineering space,
especially around the
engineers that we have.
We have a lot of software policies,
you know, risk management policies
that we're trying to automate,
and it's very straightforward
because the data is in all
the logs that we have in AWS.
So, you know, we see that
on the engineering side.
We're like, hey, how does that look
on the business side is a
very, very interesting problem.
- Definitely.
So currently, well, you mentioned
you have like 10,000 users.
Does that include Discover, or that's-
- Not yet.
- What do you expect the
number of users to be?
- Probably 15.
- (laughs) That's a
lot of risk management.
- These are practitioners.
We call them risk practitioners.
- Risk practitioners.
- They're involved in
first line, second line.
Third line wouldn't
count, but third line too.
Yeah, third line.
- Third line's on that, yeah..
- So related, so, Matt, you mentioned
about the net promoter score.
So what do you do if this score goes down?
I know it's been like (indistinct).
(panelists chuckle)
- I mean, we pull all of
our users twice a year,
and, you know, it's sort of, to me,
one of the most important exercises we get
throughout the year of
getting all of that feedback.
You know, out of that, we might,
you know, ask thousands
of users for feedback,
get, you know, 500 responses,
and a lot of people are
writing detailed comments.
So really pouring through
those to understand
like what are the pain points
and what could be even better
and using that to shape
the roadmap in the future.
Ideally this is like,
you're not learning a lot
because it's every six months,
and you know, one of the
highlights of our job
is that our users work in
the same buildings as us.
So, we should be able to just walk around
and say, "Hey, how's it going,"
and like, hear things without having
to wait for a big survey,
but it's a great touch
point to like check in
and make sure and confirm.
And we've definitely had times
when, you know, things were going wrong
and we didn't know about them
until it's like, wait a minute,
12 people said this thing.
You know, like, did you
know this was happening?
I didn't know this was happening.
And then we can jump all over it.
So we look for all those opportunities
to yeah, continue to make sure
the score is going in the right direction.
- Awesome.
All right, so with respect
to some closing questions,
I have like a few.
So, Matt, for you, if you
had to pick one key lesson
from this journey, what
would you tell peers
who are just beginning their,
you know, GRC modernization?
- Don't do it!
(Lakshman laughs)
No, seriously, I think probably
the most important thing
is know what you're getting yourself into.
It's not for the faint of heart.
It's a big investment.
It takes a lot of time, you know.
And typically we like to
develop software in an MVP form.
Like let's just ship like a little bit.
You know, we'll get feedback.
We'll iterate on it,
but this is an environment
where it's often like,
well, you can't flip all of
your risk management over
if it like doesn't really work yet.
It has to be at least as good as the thing
you're replacing before you go live.
So it can lead to longer
development cycles
than we'd like to have.
As I said, it's a big investment.
It can take a lot of time,
but I, you know, have felt the journey
is incredibly worthwhile,
but I think, you know, if you think
you can like dabble your way into it
or like, you know, this will
be like a little side project
and it'll come to fruition,
I think you need to go in eyes wide open
with understanding the level of investment
and time commitment.
- Anything you want to add, Solomon?
- I think change management was key.
I think I would say we
did a pretty good job
in anticipating what it means
to change the tires out
while still reporting
to the regulators on
your existing platform.
So risk management never stops.
You could swap the software all day long,
but you're still held
accountable every quarter
to the board, to the
regulators and examiners.
So in our case, I think
the change management
was done really well.
The harder thing was, you
know, the customer feedback,
not knowing what they want initially,
and then we are trying
to, you know, change
into a different way of thinking almost.
So that was kind of a little bit,
but then like Matt said,
the NPS has been a great
indicator of us headed
in the right direction or not.
And you have to understand,
our lease velocities are
a few hundred a month.
So we're putting features
behind feature flags.
We're deploying them.
And we have started to
now even go past the NPS
to say buy feature behind a feature flag.
Can you tell us how you feel about it?
So the experimentation changes
have started to kick in.
This is all again, evolution,
of you building software
on the cloud and the
things it allows you to do
are a lot different.
So now we started to see
even different user interaction patterns,
and user feedback loops are different.
So it's been pretty cool
the last few months.
- Yeah, so I think from
my my perspective, right,
like you are having your own
strong risk management platform
has been like a differentiator.
And from the sense
like when regulators approved
the Discover transaction,
that was part of the reason
like everybody is like,
hey, I'm using the software
every other bank uses,
and the data is as good as it gets
versus like owning this
and using this platform
reduced your like, you
know, enforcement actions
and any outstanding...
I really think that's
what like got you approval
to buy Discover.
So on the other end, right, I see still
like a lot of large financial institutions
even hesitant to go to cloud, right?
Like forget like building
risk management on their own.
They're like, oh, we
want the latest solution
that's like a cloud platform,
but we want like an on-prem version of it.
So what is your advice to
organizations that are hesitant
to leap into cloud-native risk management?
- Well, I'm like you guys
are at the AWS Conference,
so I'm assuming it's not
the people in the room,
but those of you watching
on, I don't know.
I don't think anybody's watching live,
but it's just like it's not
even a differentiator anymore.
The cloud, it's a necessity
to just to stay at par.
You're batting at par
you know, with the cloud,
or you're just gonna get left behind.
And then you look at risk management.
Like I said, risk management
has to be a lot different
than you did it before.
It's not simple credit
decisioning or credit modeling.
That's not the only way you're
gonna survive the market.
I think as AI brings in newer products
that are customized at scale
by individual user, right,
I think the whole mobile
revolution is done, right?
There's like seven and
a half billion handhelds
in the world.
So you're already customized
by individual already.
So then you think in financial products
that are customized by this individual
having a handheld across the world
and then the risk of that, right?
Matt also is our head of our
second line fraud as well.
So he's got another hat
he wears half the day,
and it's even more
interesting when you start
to think about risk
management in the fraud space.
So I just feel like if
you're not on the cloud,
you can't anticipate, you can't react,
and then I don't know how
you exist in the marketplace
as a financial services firm.
So it's gonna be key.
So if there's someone
here at the conference
and doesn't have the cloud,
I would highly recommend
the cloud to you guys.
- Thank you.
And then, Matt, to you to wrap up, right,
what does future-ready risk
organization look like to you?
- Yeah, I think it goes back
to the point we started with
of real-time intelligent risk management
where, you know, we are surfacing insights
to users based on all the
data that we've gathered.
We are helping business leaders
around the company to anticipate
what their risk might be
and what could go wrong versus reacting
when things do go wrong.
We're leaning in on generative
AI and using that to automate
and build quality into our
workflows and decisions.
But yeah, I think we're on
on a journey to get there,
but I think it's a dramatically
different worldview
when you're really managing
risks in that proactive way.
- Awesome.
Matt and Solomon, for taking your time
and thanks everyone for
joining the session.
I know it's tough to find the room.
We gotta walk past all the
free swags and the casino.
(laughs) So thank you so much for joining,
and you know, feel free to
connect with us on LinkedIn
and message there or we can meet outside
to answer any other questions.
- So thank you guys.
- All right, thank you.
(audience applauds)